what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch the
Mandalorian season 3 episode 3 today
yeah this is John yeah this is Michael
follow him MJ testler guys got two
important things to mention right off
the bat first things first Greg John and
Corey are going to be having a real
rejects panel over at WonderCon Sunday
March 26th 11 o'clock A.M be there or be
square please be there it'll be nice to
have the support I'm a YouTuber begging
you for attention and give it to us
secondly yes we cover the bad batch for
uh just due to the schedule we're gonna
have episodes that were 13 and 14. we're
gonna stack them together next week
right is that is that correct we're so
excited is it gonna be a double dose
next week I promise you guys thirdly
leave a like leave a like right guys
this is the way absolutely right this is
the way subscribe and click the
notification all right Michael they
should do that you have to and where's
Red can't handle when you're not doing
reaction watch as long as you're
sticking with your own copy of the
Mandalorian available for super sexy
reject
we got a whole bunch of crap over there
too that you'll enjoy this exclusive for
our sexy rejects alrighty let's watch
this and then I gotta edit it let's go
causes for the big energy we shot a
whole Shazam review out of the rain and
now we're watching this
the continuity
I mean the serial nature
oh look at grogu you okay Dad
I am redeemed God damn right you are
yeah you are Mandalorian again
can we leave now
[Music]
take my mask off
that's such a good point
you see anything down there
I saw the chasm passing me as I fell
I didn't realize it was so deep so I'm
at the big [__] beast did you see
anything alive
like what
um nothing
let's get out of here
she said nothing I wonder why
[Music]
next time oh man oh Dana's gonna be so
pissed when he finds out
I would invite you in for a face but I'm
guessing that helmet isn't coming off
again
this is the way
it looks like a squadron of Thai
interceptors oh oh damn whoa
get us back there and it'll reinforce
from the N1 can you evade them our
Shields aren't gonna hold
I need you to back them off
by the way there was a mythosaur down
there I forgot to mention that
oh man awesome I've skunked off a lot of
Imperial Warlords you tend to get mad
when you hijack their ships no you tell
me
man get ready we're coming in hot I
won't be able to slow down for the drop
surely they must have some defense
systems
that's shooting they're a lot tougher
than Tie fighters are you still up for
the transfer I don't see any other
choice
[Laughter]
that was awesome
oh my God go
come on man I have you now
of a Maverick right there yeah right Ave
DeLorean
oh
[Applause]
sweet got him
so much space action right yeah some
Star Wars in the Star Wars I grew up
flying these Cliffs laughs
she could shoot a Whopper at
how glorious this is damn
can anyone going after ties this is a
freaking Star Wars dream
s
[Music]
flip the ship
pull the e-brake reverse reverse
yes
oh my God Bonk
[Laughter]
you take any damage
just Shields you
not a scratch
nice shooting
I love you I know I saw a mythosaur
oh what no
what oh Thai bombers wow
to my home again I sit there
all day
oh my gosh wow
oh my God you have to get out of there
you you gotta have my kid yeah we've got
to get out of here
[Music]
cheese
that's a lot of ships for an imperial
warlord that is true I'm sending jump
coordinates to where someplace they
won't find us everyone knows about
Tatooine tin
it's one of the most traveled places
we've never been there
I didn't realize we didn't get the title
of the card yet title smash
take that helmet off
is this the song
that looks good
a red carpet event
this is the first time mandalorian's
been to Coruscant it's the first time
we've seen it after the fall of the
Empire yeah I appreciate you letting me
speak here tonight
the amnesty program saved my life this
is Pershing amnesty sadly my research
was twisted into something cruel and
inhumane at the behest of a desperate
individual oh damn though that work is
now behind me and I regret what I did
I assure you that my original intentions
were good sure he seemed like they were
he helped out when I was young I lost my
mother
the person who I admired most I'm sorry
her heart gave out
so I cloned her had simple organ cloning
been available
what my work explored was the hopes of
combining multiple strands to create
replicas that incorporated the best
genetic attributes of both donors
[Music]
thank you for coming to my TED Talk
appreciate your contribution huh of
course I'm very lucky and we're lucky
okay have you Dr Pershing how are you
finding the city
you deserve the very best doctor after
everything you've been through you're
just so afraid
I'm saying Inspirations wow
Operation Paperclip Warner Von Braun
exactly yeah
okay
join us for a drink
persian's gonna die this season G27
M40
g68
oh [__] I didn't expect to see anyone
from moff Gideon's ship here Gideon
I didn't know you worked for him
oh I heard they hooked him up to a mind
flare
mind flare huh
thanks to the rehabilitation program I
can contribute to the new Republic
just like you
[__]
long live the new Republic
along with the new Republic
oh no she's too loyal to Gideon and I've
got a bad feeling about this have you
taken in the sights on Coruscant doctor
no
I'd be happy to show you around when you
do
what do you miss all 52 Miss
from before no I'm glad that the Empire
is oh not like that
she's so worried about being judged
maybe those
yellow
travel biscuits
if I never see another ration pack in my
life I'll die happy all right I want
something dry I'll just listen to your
joke
[Laughter]
it's not
this is crazy how we're here right now
yeah and like really spending time
inside of it oh
travel biscuits
how'd you get that yeah that's weird not
suspect at all
[Music]
it's that last one made him
oh I saw your talk last night really
interesting stuff I had no idea you're
so experienced I wonder why the heavy
down here
yeah you know oh oh excuse me
I'll let you get back to it thank you
again yeah
this is all just a little too awkward
for me or you could feel something
something percolating so many people
it's all a bit overwhelming
[Laughter]
you've been a course on before
it's trained here at the Academy
really we thought we were doing good
I do think about that sometimes for sure
we're close to making some incredible
breakthroughs
and the right hands our discoveries
could have helped a lot of people
why not continue your research here
don't think it's something the new
Republic would be interested in be
careful ethics of cloning are
complicated
but if it could help the new Republic
isn't that important enough oh my God it
begins
the new Republic is trying their best
but they're struggling sure a lot of
capable people who want to help
you understand what I'm saying
she's manipulating you
[Music]
what is that it's a rock you want to
touch it are we allowed to allowed live
a little dog it's not the Empire
I love the use of other Star Wars music
in the background here I just love
seeing this aspect of the culture
[Music]
buddies refrain from physical contact
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh the look on your face was priceless
I ship them nothing will happen
[Music]
should be more biscuits
room full of biscuits
are you able to maintain a consistent
schedule
yes are you experiencing any undue
stress some Blade Runner [__] if I were
to pursue my own research would that be
allowed that class of research is
expressly prohibited by the chorus and
Accords
do you have any further questions
I guess not
oh dude thank you for continuing to be
an important part of the amnesty program
have a nice day I'm feeling some anger
towards the new Republic right now once
the war criminal always a word coming
he's gonna break bad he's literally
start making clothes are you Genesis
I know it's important and in the hands
of the new Republic it can actually be
used for good
I just need to prove it
start with Palpatine
stop snooking around you want to help
the new Republic they just can't see it
yet
we can get you a mobile app station
men are stupid
but it would require going outside our
designated perimeter Heist
no
I've done a lot of things I'm ashamed of
I have a lot to make up for I don't
believe you if your research really is
as important as you say I'll take that
risk sleep on it okay
people were wrong maybe she is a good
guy just stop
she's so strong though with such a
strong person be so mean I believe her I
think he's got a heart of goal I'm
kidding it's Imperial technology yes but
it can still be put to good use can I be
honest with you it would require
authorization from the Department I know
it's not easy I assure you this is truly
helping the new Republic
finish these TPS reports this is the
most and or like episode have you
experienced any feelings of anger or
resentment towards the new republic
government or its Representatives
apologies if you didn't hear me
have you experienced any feelings of
anger or resentment no
our main objective is to help the
Republic right correct and that
supersedes everything else
it does
it's time for a heist
the mobile lab station
let's go get it
good
tomorrow night
this music's reassuring as one of those
looks furtively to the side and back
you're helping the new Republic
it's the right thing to do
you're a good guy
there's something in those businesses
controlling his brainwashed
remember why we're doing this
public
uh just like New York
loving the music
so unsettling
songs days am I right
[Laughter]
good she only had like five lines last
season I could see where they gave her
more where are we going disposal yards
Imperial ships will have mobile lab
stations right they do but they're
Imperial
we slip in grab what you need and we're
back at amnesty housing before you know
it
have you done this before
or do you think I got the biscuits
from the scrap yard
wowzy so beautiful it's like an almost
nautical quality to this stuff what if
Gideon's there and she's taking it she's
just waiting under a piece of rubbles
all right
row
follow me
I feel like buying tickets would have
made this easier for them oh yeah a
little bit go ahead I'm right behind you
oh boy
yeah
so too long
oh what is this Riff Raff doing here
tongs days am I right
no read your read your audience
[Music]
[Laughter]
she's got Michael Myers ticket
attendance
assistant
it's okay doc you can make it Yep this
is just me and Red Dead Redemption
thought you liked biscuits
love
I don't think this is love this is
manipulation Mike love what's the
difference
well that was really lucky
look at those airbag boxes
how convenient it's Imperial Air needs
to be decommissioned
[Music]
oh no
whoa
Destroyer
oh man
what a shot
never done anything like this before
we all we all know there's one thing
that's been made clear
stuff
that was his first time on a subway like
[Laughter]
spend a lot of time scrapping big ships
in Star Wars yeah I would take you ages
to rip one of these apart you sure we're
alone
yep
ships are all inoperable
no need to guard them yeah famous last
words
they're tiny flashlights
I must have passed you on Gideon's ship
a hundred times
the courage to say hi
[Music]
Elia Kane
Communications officer
a liar came
oh wow
oh boy this is perfect
only take what I need
so I'll go into the scrap Heap
where are you gonna set this [__] up
what did you want to be when you grow up
I didn't really have a chance to think
about it
just the ship settling
keep hacking
you what did you have a woman
run
[Music]
oh oh no
keep moving
I appreciate the one with no muscles
carrying the heavy box
yeah off
stop
wowie to sell 52 raise your hands you
were under arrest
no maybe she was working
with them
[Music]
oh what
raise your hands up into two whoa she
was the good guy
wait wait
no it's not good what maybe she's
working for the new Republic the new
Republic has some ugly things up their
sleeve amnesty officer g68 has already
submitted a report
yeah she bullshitted man whoa nice I
think there's been a mistake
and Dr Nation by the Empire is
challenging to overcome
this is Eerie this is very eerie this is
a mind flare this is a 602 mitigator no
it's a mind flare yeah it's a similar
device
it can be used to help soothe select
traumatic memories let's go shop therapy
you're gonna wipe my mind absolutely not
this isn't the Empire so I'm New
Republic is evil I was just trying to
help
this will only take a moment
you don't understand
she brought me there it was a trap
you racist how many times I gotta hear
that in the day you set me up
Black Mirror [__] man I love it really
what is subvert expectation you've done
the right thing
thanks oh she's trying to work her way
into the new Republic's trust you are a
real credit to this program it's nice to
know that for every failure there's a
success like you
oh no 3D
shall we
do you mind if I stay
I still care about him of course you do
yes you're welcome to stay she can Flay
his mind into getting what she wants out
of him
so honey
that's exactly what's happening
it's so cruel
oh oh my
she's gonna eat a cookie
biscuits biscuits my bad my b
itch okay
a Mandalorian covert this is how we have
survived in Exile I'm familiar oh no oh
God she hasn't taken off her helmet
since it will go smoother if you keep
your helmet on trust me
of course
you can hear the smile on her tone this
is gonna be great
[Music]
there's John Favreau she's friends with
so many of Islas
[Music]
the minds were collapsed in The Purge
the planet is cursed these are lies
meant to keep us in Exile
yes and who are you night owl
mm-hmm
I am bogatan of Clan creese your house
has fallen from the way you are both
apostates
guys I bring proof
[Music]
we shall see
oh the armor would have some way of
telling all this technology they don't
have a camera
look at all these spin-off shows we're
looking at right here
the book of all these guys
I have proof
[Music]
he's not a fan of Boca tan nope he fell
into the depths then I pulled him out
oh we pinned out of there
[Music]
speaks the truth
this is the way this is the way
and Bo Katan Crees you too are redeemed
oh
did you bathe in the waters technically
I did
and have you removed your helmet since
no then you may join our covert and live
as your ancestors once did
welcome Bo Katan of Clan crease
this is the way this is the way
you had it in your man
was not happy
I feel bad
[Music]
wow I don't know where this Show's going
and I've been loving it it's Lee I'm
loving it don't know where it's going
cool cool great wow damn this is
different this is very very difficult
they're going big here like how we cut
back to I just yarn in them I'm glad
that we did yeah
get a whole episode of someone else it's
a nice like Oreo remember how fun the
first episode was yeah
I bet you wish you could go back there
now that's so dark at the last two
episodes this is the way all right that
was awesome that was awesome
um
wow so different so different in every
way
I mean wasn't there a character recently
who said that some line that was clever
about new Republican Empire not being
too different from each other we're
seeing it yeah I I think uh
any bureaucracy is going to have these
shortcomings and I love that not America
yeah do what you talk about we're
perfect we are perfect we've been
perfect we're the only Generations
we have never swayed not to keep getting
better not once no I mean it was so cool
going back to Coruscant and seeing as
much of as things have changed they also
haven't
um and we learn no lessons uh at all
ever in both our real history and in
Star Wars history
um but what a tone I mean that it felt
like Andor did feel like Andor just a
little bit
CGI or yeah you could tell that volume
yeah
I'm gonna get my one complaint out of
the way my one complaint because
everything else I really actually loved
about this episode my one little
complaint is that this was the first
time in all of Mandalorian where I was
like I'm very much aware of the of the
CGI this time and I'm normally not hyper
aware this was something about when you
step in a Coruscant and that clone wars
and uh I mean pretty cool thing yeah
it's just it's the one part too much on
it because I was barely I barely ever
notice it with the show Yeah well yeah
it's like it's such a lighting heavy
place and such a spread out and Sleek
place too that I think it's yeah it's
really hard to get everything exactly
right and your ability to build any kind
of practical aspect of that set is just
infinitely more difficult than it is
when you're in grungeville yeah yeah uh
yeah but no I mean they had the same
issue too in Obi-Wan you know in the
flashback sequence Obi-Wan
that yeah but it's uh
I'm just so stoked that all of my
expectations and I feel you
I feel like everyone keeps getting
thrown off course of wherever we think
this is going to go yeah I mean even
like clearly I was like oh she's clearly
the bad guy and then for that minute
we're like oh wait a second she's the
good guy and like oh no wait she's the
bad guy
um well I never thought for a second
even when he was caught because she was
kept egging him on
he kept saying I still think she's go
get this [__] Go Get It Go Get It yeah
oh no look you're bad
she did lure him let's push him into it
yeah I I don't I don't see it that way I
saw a friend who was simply trying to
help her friends see the light oh yeah
yeah the burning visceral light of a
mindset
uh yeah no I mean it was I I mean I love
when we get these like World War II
Espionage like Thriller things at a Star
Wars uh and I I feel like
Star Wars historically speaking it's
always lending from Real History and its
storytelling and this was such a good
example I mean like the idea of like
yeah what happened to the Imperial
soldiers and they're they're brought in
and their skills are used for the new
Republic and like the same way that like
NASA hired Nazis to like build the Space
Program
um and I think that's just a fun thing
to play around with I mean yeah it has
the fun with like the charade of
nationalism within the new Republic you
know like look how great and and uh
prosperous everything is but we kind of
just hunt all the bad [__] and we
actually do some real evil [__] to make
sure you conform but we're gonna pitch
it to you like it's something of beauty
but not in the way the like they do a
lot of I really like that they're
actually handling that and uh I was
really I was willing to not cut back to
dinjarin in Boca tan for this episode it
would have been a weird structure if it
was just the beginning and then just
pushing and did you get her name
you can release the cast for this son of
a [__] it's just it's just Pedro Pascal
Carl Weathers who did not appear yes
um I mean yeah she's briefly in in
season two uh but yeah I mean I thought
she did I thought she gave a great
performance I think it's really cool
that you got these two characters person
who's appeared a few times by now but to
get these two characters to really
expand on their screen time and flesh
out the amount of characters but also
really allow these actors to really act
like really give them some Journey to go
on in a uh especially for Persian to get
such an inner conflict who's who has
such a if there's something so tragic
about this guy because I do think he's
very sincere in wanting to have done
good like we've seen him help out in in
season two we saw him really help out
when he was caught I was like no don't
worry I'm going to show you how to get
scrotum I'm gonna help you out and it
wasn't like that you have me caught I'm
trying to get to get it like he was
really trying to be a positive Aid to
them and you could see that he felt
terrible about the way everything was
going that he was sort of his hand was
being forced yeah so I do I do feel like
pitiful for the guy and and then her you
know like I just don't allow myself to
be swayed by such [__] she would
hurt evil that at the
Enderman she was she was doing him a
favor
I mean what kind of life is this guy
really got to look forward to am I right
yeah if if biscuits are the best you got
you know uh no I I I completely agree
and and I feel like something that uh
the mandalorians did a great job of is
bringing to life some of these like
Imperial caricatures in a way that
really lets you care about them
um and like we saw last season uh uh
with uh Bill Burr's uh character
Mayfield yeah which I just I loved how
all that played out and I think this is
such an interesting Dynamic
um you know I feel what what she was
saying about like her upbringing and she
didn't really have a choice and all that
I'm sure she's gonna have a pretty
compelling motivation for being aligned
with the Empire uh and and I'm I'm
excited to really quick to interrupt you
believe just to clarify you believe that
she what she's doing is not because I
was like there's two ways I could take
this with what's happening with her one
she's secretly doing some Empire [__]
yeah or two
um she's been so brainwashed by a new
Republic by all these like experimental
things she's doing that she's doing this
in in certain but she but she's going
about the methods that she learned from
the Empire which is the full-on
punishment I I think she's looking to
create a true Democratic now
no I I definitely think you know that
the imperial Remnant what's left of it
uh Operation Center which you know they
talked about a little bit in season two
like there is that first order you know
that that contingency plan of the Empire
and uh I think she's a loyalist and
subscribes to it and definitely that
means embedding herself I mean she did a
double whammy here number one she like
took a a a player off the the chess
board that was really could completely
change the the trajectory of the Galaxy
you know by bringing cloning back and
then two sharing the trust of the new
Republic as oh here's this really
talented former Imperial that very
clearly cares about the new Republic
um and they seem pretty naive and
accepting of uh of people yeah um I'm
fascinated as to what they're going to
attempt to say about the new Republic in
doing this because it does imply yeah
like her cranking it all the way up in
the end goes really hard in a way I
wasn't expecting out of Star Wars and so
I was wondering like is uh are they
telling the truth to him when they're
like yeah this is very similar to a mind
flare but don't worry we've it's like
electroshock therapy we're like it's
still used today to much lesser extent
and can actually help you and so yeah
I'm wondering it's like are they going
to com comment on the incompetence of an
organization like the new Republic or
are they going to kind of liken
authoritarianism to authoritarianism you
know when it all goes awry or
bureaucracy is a better way to put that
well I I think look no further than the
sequels right like the whole idea of the
resistance sequels the sequels the
sequels mine just go outside and look at
it
[Laughter]
was that her last name
yeah so but but look to the the sequel
yes did I do it no uh it and and you
have the you know Leia gets frustrated
with the new Republic for this exact
reason because this just gets
continuously worse over the course of
the years
um and ultimately there's like a very
obvious evil threat on on the edge of
the Galaxy being the first order
um and I I feel like that's what the
Mandalorian and a lot of this the
content that's being made uh you know
between the originals and the seek whole
tree of the seagull trilogies uh we're
making up for for
things that would have been really nice
to have had fleshed out prior to the the
sequels coming out that's true I mean
yeah we did have that episode I think
Carl Weathers directed that episode when
they introduced Operation Center or at
least the interesting title of it yeah
which comes from Battlefront too got it
um yeah where we see it kind of
firsthand destroying cities and uh and
it was basically the emperor's like well
if if if you won't uh Mayfield that was
Mayfield though when he yeah
that was a rick Family episode yes but
you're absolutely right
um and it was they attacked Imperial
worlds uh including one of the planets
that was supposed to be destroyed and
that was saved was Naboo
well I mean we are getting to because I
was thinking about the episode when they
did see the like yeah you're right we
got to get the Snopes and all that [__]
we do we do have to go through it yeah
thank you but but I think it's I think
it's interesting because obviously
they're setting that up but I feel like
they're also setting up something even
Grandeur outside of that you know thank
God I can't just be please please don't
just fill in the blank for her no
weirdest effort you know I think the
question is where do the mandalorians
fit in and I think that's what I'm most
excited about it uh because it's it's
the one question mark that like
what is the significance of them coming
back Beyond like oh it's great they're
back on Mandalore like they're clearly
going to have some kind of implication
on the the greater Galaxy and the
direction it goes
um and I think you know we look towards
the unknown regions yes and all the
others are worth content but I won't get
into that
[Music]
um yeah why do you think Boca Tan's not
mentioning the mythosar
I feel oh well I mean I feel like they
could be like a major asset of some kind
if she could come back riding that thing
you know yeah you could keep your dirty
dark saber I feel like I don't know that
could be an easy way to sort of Ally
yourself with like a primal force that
exists on this place and especially if
the pockets of the remaining you know
mandalorians across the Galaxy don't
believe that it's possible or that it's
there I mean this moment obviously puts
at least a bit of credibility to the
idea that it is there that the planet is
not cursed and inhabitable uninhabitable
um but I don't know yeah I feel like
that that that's like a uh some weird
Ace up the sleeve or something like that
that she can maybe she can send them in
there unprepared or maybe she can use it
to her advantages I think what's
interesting is originally I thought that
we were setting up and I think it's
still the case between the armor and
Boca 10 but
I feel like she's smart and she's out of
mandalorians like her people are gone
yeah but she just found a whole new crew
she's gonna try to use them I I think
that that's really the the power Dynamic
that's going to play out instead of it
being people that we haven't met on her
side and then you know but in terms of
of the mythosaur part of me really
wonders like genuinely I wonder if she
doesn't even necessarily believe it
herself
um if if
she's wondering if in that moment she
had some kind of uh I think her question
to den was sincere uh
did you see something like I mean if you
saw a sea monster underwater while
you're going scuba diving uh you know
you saw what the Loch Ness monster you'd
be like did anybody else say anything
you wouldn't explicitly say like I saw
the Loch Ness monster and you'd spend
the rest of your life questioning if you
ever really happened but this isn't like
the the real world where you encounter
something that is
in the Star Wars Rolex I've seen a lot
of crazy [__] yes but big monsters are
all around yeah but this is I I this is
like the ultimate I mean this is like
one day you're like going to the North
Pole and it's like oh my God that's
actually Santa Claus like that's what
the equivalent of the mythosaur is and
that's coming from a Jew so uh it would
be especially no surprise yeah actually
we know he's real
[Laughter]
uh yeah I could I could see it being
that case
um where she
I feel like there's something
antagonistic up her sleeve maybe she's
already been there and she's already
tamed it yeah and then maybe she's just
like hey you didn't you didn't see that
but my Secret's still cool right it's
not so easy to tame him yeah but you
know she's had time and everybody thinks
it's a curse plan especially on their
territory underwater they're very very
very hard
she's on a spiritual journey to find her
faith right now and I don't know if she
there's no one would just suddenly slap
a [__] house
I mean I and I don't I don't think it's
it's like that as much as
she's getting back to basics you know at
its core what does it really mean to be
a Mandalorian and you know she original
Mandalore with the dark city
violence before but before Mandalore was
ruled by mandalores with the dark saber
it was ruled by those who rode
mythosaurus yeah so you know and I I
think going back to those ancient roots
and she's seen the Folly of she's done
everything else she's tried every other
path so maybe
this is the way ah nicely done nicely
done thank you well I mean yeah there's
a lot of great things to pull from here
but I I do think that just overall as an
episode they they had a great sense of
intrigue and uh Strong's they had that
great way of like never giving in too
much to saying like there's something up
here even though you could just feel the
whole time like something is gonna go
wrong like you just sort of trust the
show that this can't all go good no way
in hell yeah you know something's gonna
go wrong and even though the trust for I
can't remember her name but whatever her
name is whatever the truster was is a
wavering place it did a great job on
I didn't see it coming at all what was
actually going to happen at that moment
so I think they did an excellent job on
T like man this is the first time the
mandalorians done an episode where you
are right this is the first time I've
done one where you are not with Mano
you're not with ninjarin for most of
them yeah they it's kind of a risk for
an episode to do yeah where it can feel
like disconnected but you also have
faith that it's actually going to
connect unlike you know like something
like what Boba Fett does or you're just
like let's just go to the other show
let's go to Mandu okay this doesn't feel
that way well it's it's
as as we're scoping out a little bit uh
I feel like book of Boba Fett and where
that fits into all of this is the
combination of content that's being made
right now is collectively one series
definitely
um they're built into something bigger
yeah uh the Mandalore the movie uh yeah
but I thought this did I think they
learned some lessons maybe from Boba
Fett and did nicely to make it so that I
think the book ends of this episode
complement the middle part really well
because you're at two polar ends of the
spectrum basically you're at the sort of
you know crest of reaching toward the
you know the The Highest Potential on
Coruscant and rebuilding this new
Republic here with these new ideologies
and then on the opposite end you have
this really dedicated like ancient
ideology that is finding its way closer
to its roots kind of going backwards in
a sense and you have two people pushing
in Boca 10 Yeah Yeah well yeah you have
both Italian you have the girls so it's
like they're both kind of embedded in a
way into a different version of
Something familiar for them and now
you're watching
the kind of moral array of things that
could happen and I feel like you have
the dark version happening on Coruscant
and what could potentially be the light
version but I also agree that there
seems to be some other shoe that's going
to drop with focatana may put her at
odds and I feel like they they
proportioned this well to have those
themes complement nicely and also feel
Punchy with these no you bring up such a
great Point John like I think the moral
of the story is the new Republic no
lessons have been learned the
mandalorians nothing but lessons
happening yeah yeah uh and we're gonna
see the results of that well I mean it
helps that Pershing and and Boca tan
thematically there's there's something
that thematically feels similar to the
experience that they're going through of
a questioning of their belief system you
know and uh what they have to like
especially with Boca tan like and how
can I contribute to the new system of
things yeah yeah but uh like do I
the Pershing is part of a new community
with new republic versus Empire
bocatan's not part of this Mandalorian
culture yeah she has always been like
yeah which is such a fascinating uh
we're we're going to a place
thematically in Star Wars that we've
never gone before and that is
I'm sorry
the cosmos
[Laughter]
alrighty guys well what did you think
about this episode I thought it was
awesome
um I thought it was really really
awesome I feel like we all thought it
was great
so thank you so much for being here
um leave a like if you like biscuits
subscribe click that Bell keep a lookout
for our reaction in next week's episode
don't forget we got WonderCon but before
we head out let's end this with a
patreon
I think he is a perfect person to shout
out for this because Mikhail I could
totally see you becoming amandalorian
yeah in every way you know as a matter
of fact I'd prefer you with the helmet
on I've only seen like your profile pic
but sometimes when you got a sexy body
you know what I would like is that a
best car armor just you nude with the
helmet oh
my God
yeah I think that would be amazing yeah
I mean all that Swedish cheesy you gotta
offer you know what I'm saying buddy
Sweden yes yeah this is the way maybe
[Laughter]
um but we love you but also thanks for
being here for so long you've been a
long time supporter and I appreciate
your your support with um
being able to hire people like your your
Patron uh contribution goes to pay
Michael that's it
and let me let me just say if I could
have a little bit of your blood I'm sure
it would show that your M count is high
there Mike Drive reference Michael drop
oh
um